are you dr spaniel i'm daisy's mom
oh it's so lovely to meet you thank you
for showing an interest in my daughter
daisy sofia jimenez who was born in the
los angeles county hospital on
july 12 2005. of course
should we step into my office uh it's
actually a custom
among my people that we go for a walk
outside when we first meet a person
and i feel uncomfortable questioning you
on that so let's do it
okay now that spin was busy with your
fake mom all that you have to do is hide
in your office and then intercept the
call from your real mom wait
i forgot am i pretending to be my mom no
because then your mom would be talking
to your mom
sorry i should have slapped you earlier
my name is jessie spano
i'd like to buy a volvo
dr spanol's office i am her hi
this is anna jimenez returning your call
why hello miss jimenez
i'm daisy's guidance counselor as you
can tell by my voice i am way
congratulations so what was it you
wanted to talk to me about
ah yes the thing i wanted to talk to you
about that thing is
[Music]
um that thing is
that your daughter is excelling at
bayside
oh that's wow okay
[Music]
um so that's it yep guess i didn't need
to call you bye
[Music]
it was so great meeting you and
i know i keep saying this but you really
look like that lady from the gum
commercial
me with these pearly whites
[Music]
you